Okay, audio.
Okay, maybe.
I just started.
You just started.
No, no, no, no.
Moi moi boo I got a new pop filter everybody So let me know
How it sounds If it sounds any different at all Gonna be
peak Peak As you can see We're playing a merry Bunny garden
Not like merry As in like Marry them If only What if you can
though Who knows But this is not i don't know what is this a
sequel i have no idea my advice for today get yourself a
donut i got one i got one i got a donut um it was really
delicious it was like the first thing i did what kind i love
okay i either like uh a boston cream donut or like a glazed
donut but the chocolate, not the glazed being chocolate but
the donut is chocolate and the glaze is the normal glaze.
You know?
Winta, if you're doing well today, it's my birthday!
Smoky rubies!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Boston Grip is so pink, it's so good, right?
I got the glaze, the chocolate glaze one though.
I got that one and I was like This is delicious I was so
happy Kira I'm watching this stream on my flight right now
Wait this game Maybe this isn't a good idea No you should
full screen it You should full screen it Oh my gosh you guys
Right before the stream Kira messaged me about my upcoming
3D Jazz a concert which um there will be streaming tickets
can we have a bite of the donut oh sorry i already ate it
that was yesterday i got it but um uh wait why are you
saying kiwawa is she here kiwawa i don't see her
I said Kiara.
Wait, what did I say?
Wait.
I mentioned her.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I meant Kiara.
Oh, I said Kiara, not Kiara, you guys.
I said Kiara, not Kiara.
Kiara is of Oshi Spark.
Kira of Oshi Spark messaged me a the jazz club and they had
a question okay this might this I guess will spoil one of
the songs but that's okay because maybe it's a given but I
they asked about the song can't say goodbye to yesterday
which I have a cover out actually of that song on my channel
it's from Metal Gear Solid 2 and the the They asked because,
you know, it's going to be a live band.
And so they were like asking about doing a different
rendition of it.
Like, because the song is very long.
Maybe you're cutting it down a little bit.
And but but sorry.
Oh, whoops.
I clicked out of the game on accident.
The the the the the the the band member that asked was like,
Hi, I was asking about the song.
Can't say goodbye to yesterday.
sung by the lovely Carla White.
And, because yeah, Carla White sung the original.
And then the band member said, I worked with her in New York
in the 70s and 80s and they never knew about the song.
Isn't that crazy?
Like what a tiny small world.
Isn't that so cool?
I was like, wow.
Like, oh my gosh, I can't believe that they found out, found
a piece of work of hers that they never knew about.
And but they worked with her before.
Video games.
Video games connect, connect everybody.
That's so cool.
I was like, whoa.
Now I want to pick their brain about her though.
Now that also makes me feel more nervous.
I hope I do the song justice so that they're like, ah, it's
like she's back.
Being there live to hear you sing that song would have been
my year.
Well, it will still be live and I will hopefully have more
opportunities to sing it live too, so.
You'll do fine.
I'll do my best But now I have to Practice a different
version of the song So More homework for me But yeah Welcome
to Mary Mary Bunny Garden So I thought I would have my cat
ears on But then I was like I wonder If that would be kind
of intimidating to the bunny girls You know what I mean?
Because know cats can hunt bunnies I'm on the prowl I'm on
the prowl for some bunny girl maybe I should but I thought
being a bunny girl would be cuter anyway I got big old
floppy ears I like I like the big old ears and um and Uh...
I'm not as...
Well...
Um...
Have you had to listen to Uma Umah cover of Bokura Not yet,
I haven't listened to any of the cover songs yet, the Love
Life cover songs?
Intimidating meow there?
Meow!
Meow meow meow meow meow Wait, I can't be a cat, I'm a bunny
so I go...
Wait, don't bunnies kind of squeak sometimes?
And then my nose goes...
And I...
Bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Which I do not have many, maybe as much bounce as some of
the lovely ladies behind me, but I can... Actually, no!
You know what?
That's not true!
I've got... I've got all your bounce right there!
You see that?
Look at that bounce, look at that bounce, look at that, look
at them go, look at them go, look at them break down, break
down, break.
Bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce,
bounce.
Look at them go, look at them go, look at them go.
Bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Look at that guy.
Actually, if I take off my jacket.
Bounce, bounce.
Oh, well...
Bounce.
Okay, I'm embarrassed.
It's fine.
It's okay, because...
Well, you're not looking at my bounce anyway.
You're looking at the bunny girls, so it's totally...
Okay!
Best part about Minto her bounce and wiggles.
That one guy should not full screen the stream on the plane.
Is that me as Heisenberg?
Is your profile picture me as Walter Heisenberg White?
I mean, your pop-out already said you have literally no
bounce parameters.
But there's seriously something going on there.
You convinced me to choose Boston Cream instead of vanilla
dip.
Let's go!
Today's my birthday, I turned 34 today, and I'm enjoying
myself a yummy triple chocolate cake right now.
Abraham, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Airflow.
Guys, I'm on season five episode I think I just finished
episode 10.
Season five of Breaking Bad.
I am just a few, I am six episodes away from finishing the
series.
And then I can move on to the movie and then I can move on
to Better Call Saul.
I accidentally nicked my head shaving again.
Not too bad.
And now I'm feeling sad.
Can I get a healing?
Healing girl.
Beep.
Wow, just like Walter did.
He did that too in the show.
Better Call Saul is even better.
That's what I've heard.
That Better Call Saul is like one of the greatest TV shows
of all time.
And I also didn't, I thought originally that the show,
because I've heard so many good things about it, Mito makes
my heart bounce.
Because I heard so many good things about it, and I feel
like for so long, I thought it was a show that came out
immediately following Breaking Bad, but I didn't realize it
came out in like 2022, so, so excited to see this vibe
getting demonetized.
Yeah, yeah, I'm expecting that.
Yeah, pretty recent.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm very excited because...
Hi, Donkey Minto.
Don't call me a donkey.
Oh, it finished in 2022.
Oh, the Netflix lied to me.
But, um...
My favorite characters are Mike and Saul anyway, so I'm very
excited about a show about them.
So...
I'll never forgive you, Walter White.
I'll never forgive you.
Mike having his, like, this is good, isn't it moment.
Oh, I'm so...
I was seething.
I cried.
I cried, and I, like, was so angry.
I, like, had to take a walk.
I was so...
I was so bad.
I was...
Anyway, we're not talking about Breaking Bad today, though.
But I think I'm going to have to, like...
I think what I'm going to do is watch the last three
episodes.
So 14, 15, 16.
Do like a little watch-along.
But since I'm almost there...
I need to like...
Wait.
Maybe do it before stream.
in one of these days or something.
Sorry, hi, umma, minto-um-me- No!
No, I'm a bunny!
Actually, I think I used these for umma ears before.
They don't- they- I mean, they do look like umma ears, don't
they?
A little bit!
Not the size of the boy and it's the girl they're attached
to.
Exactly.
Ho-Shell Spoiler Cast But today we're playing Merry Bunny
Garden Which might be a rage game This is not the Bunny
Garden original So in this game we are directing these Three
lovely ladies home As they stumble through Akihabara Because
they are drunken messes No half measures, Minky Give the
Bunny Girls your full measures My Oshi, the donkey.
I'm not a donkey.
They're gonna take Akiba.
So true.
I think they're drunk.
Oh, customer information.
Bunny Garden is a social place for later...
Oh, okay.
Is it on auto?
Takizo, thank you so much for the podcast.
They're like, you've played this game, before.
You don't need to.
I think they're already drunk.
Prepared us for gentlemen to heal their daily fatigue.
Bunny Garden.
And gentle ladies.
Yeah, I'm here too.
I'm a gentle lady.
My name is Kana.
One of the cast members here.
Let's have a lot of fun together today.
Who got her like this?
I'll take the girl in the bottom right.
Not for sale, not for sale!
Daki, thanks for the gift!
Hey, so welcome to Mamu's ship, Darkroo.
I love disasters.
What does that mean?
Kana, why are you talking to an empty city?
She's hallucinating?
Wait, or the bar is haunted?
Kana, why are you talking to an empty city?
The store has been long closed and it's just us here.
I think she's...
I think it's haunted?
Me?
Ah!
Okay, when I played Bunny Garden, I remember Rin being my
favorite.
So if she also loves ghosts, she's gonna take care of me!
We don't have that!
It's been so long since I've been taken care of.
Oh, I think she's attacking me.
Oh, really?
Even better.
We need a dead body boat.
No, we need a dead body boat.
I'm just, I'm just a bit.
I'm too much.
I'm just a bit on a bit on.
No, she drank too much today.
We're all wobbly.
Wobbly, wobbly, wobbly.
Bellow.
Oh!
Oh, boy, bellow.
No, Kamisama, please.
The godlight.
Please, disappear.
No!
Wobbly boobs.
You can't flash your boobs!
The store is closed.
Why are they still there?
My beloon.
Mint didn't get the 18 plus patch.
I don't think that exists for this game.
Watching your streams during a tattoo session, I think this
game is...
Destroying my tattoo artist!
This is made by Cynran Kagura people.
No, this is Q-rate.
My wobblies.
My wobbl- I'm gonna start referring to them as that.
My wobblies, even though they don't wobble so much.
Kana has already seen the wobblies.
I just felt like dancing.
What does this mean?
What's happening?
Do you always get naked when you dance?
Why is she crying now?
What's happening?
Why are you crying?
Because...
Even though you saw Rin's wobblies kind of won't look at
mine.
Oh no, she's like white girl wasting.
That's why you got all sad and teary.
I'm real sorry.
They're there.
That's on me.
Come here, Miuka-chan.
Come here, Miuka-chan, I'll treat you like a good girl.
Come, come.
Mama.
Mama?
I'm looking forward to it.
That's when you guys are wobbling around.
I'm like, hey, wobblies.
Kya, kya, kya!
Yip!
They switched characters.
Miyuka is the motherly one.
This isn't right, this isn't okay.
But even I want to be spoiled sometimes.
I want to be spoiled all the time.
Why are we on the CG for so long?
Even Miyuka has days when she wants to be pampered.
You can be as spoiled as you want.
You guys would spoil me, right?
Momi, momi.
Oh, squeeze.
Where did she squeeze it?
Oh, I didn't give you permission to fondle me!
Kha-kha!
No, sorry, I'm just a mid.
The music is so...
This is the peppermint club.
Kana, what's wrong?
I'm gonna be you also want to be pampered.
Shows got to be pampered.
Shows to be nice.
All right, Kana, I'll pamper you too.
Dekchune!
Eekchune!
What the heck are we doing?
That's cruel.
Don't just wake up on Nero and all of a sudden.
I wish I could crawl into a hole.
She's gaining sentience, you guys.
Don't you have like other staff that work here that can like
escort Yuhu?
So we should call a taxi?
No, no.
Can we call a taxi?
No.
No, no.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm going to violently throw up, she's so Oh, she always
causes trouble by getting sick in the car.
I'm going to violently throw up.
She's so honest.
The road home is full of dangers.
What are their bears?
Oh, it is Japan.
Sly.
Yeah, there could be slimes or goblins.
I don't have the confidence to get home safely.
I'm scared.
I'm scared, Kuna.
Nin-chan.
Gyo!
Ah!
I...
...tuck.
Oh, she hugged her.
...
...my princess.
She couldn't have said that any slower.
A little spell to get home safely.
That got her good.
Their body's getting high.
I thought you guys were sobering up unless this is how they
normally talk to each other my honey
hello where's master Minto happy to see you are revisiting
the gem my math man thank you actually no this game came out
like a couple it came out not too long ago i think a couple
months ago right miyoka chan's turn oh oh get open vomit
vomit blast
it went down just before the blast oh was she gonna throw up
Wait!
Oh, she was gonna throw.
Should I, should I throw?
I'm gonna throw up.
I always want someone to massage my booty.
Oh, yeah, everybody, drink some water.
I feel so sick.
I think I'm going to...
I think I'm going to flower.
No, I'm just kidding.
Let's get home safely and meet here again with a smile.
Me
and again with a smile.
I'm glad they're so proud.
about the workplace.
They're so big.
I think that was my one issue with the game is there's no
variety in the Opie size of the girls.
They all have the same...
Maybe it's like you have to be this big to ride this ride.
You know?
You have to...
Oh, I looked into the bunny garden it closed.
Oh, that's the achievement I got?
It's kind of...
On the screen, you can select a character to go home.
Other than Kanam, more characters will unlock as you
progress through several episodes.
Let's start by sending Kanam!
Alright, guys.
Okay, we have to get through one...
Stage one, two of Kanas stage.
What other costumes do we have?
Flower garden.
Wait, post switch?
Post switch?
Breeze?
Wait, this is what she's wearing, don't all?
Hey!
I'm being lied to right now!
I'm being lied to!
This is a cute face though, this one.
Oh wait, why can't you see my... hold on.
I can't you see my cursor.
There we go.
This is a good face.
Do you have some censorship setting on?
I don't think so, I don't think.
I don't think...
Stockings!
Ooh, I like the socks too though.
We'll go with the stockings.
Okay.
Select an episode.
Streaming sensor.
I don't have that.
We'll see what happens if something, if it is the same in
the future, then I will.
I will check it out.
stage on the screen.
Choose a difficulty.
Wasted.
Clearing the stage, the next stage will be unlocked.
If you beat a stage with a high score, a secret seed will be
unlocked.
Okay.
Sweet size and hot skin.
Alright, we're just getting home.
I don't know.
Let's go for the normal mode.
Wait.
What if we do wasted?
Wasted.
Let's try wasted.
I want to see what's of highest difficulty.
Wait, Rin looks so cute in her casual clothes.
Oh,
she's got the chance.
She's so clumsy.
She's just gotta go home like that.
Yeah.
Let's walk part way home together today.
I'll be there to protect you.
That's not me, that's a utility pole!
Oh, sorry, Rin-chan.
Oh, wait, are they in front of you DX right now?
Is this the area of- behind would be the former is a former
Gundam cafe and now it's a what's that what's that uh
Tamashi store and then over here would be the station and
then this is this looks like it's supposed to be UDX right
here oh I think so
I know we're both drugged but it's a shock to be mistaken
for utility pole.
Ikimbi Cafe!
I only got to go once.
Wait, why are they all the way over here?
Because I know where the Bunny Garden location is.
It's not close to here at all.
It's like all the way down here.
Or no, all the way over there.
Sorry.
Huh.
Hmm.
Why are they all the way over here?
Look at...
Try touching my body.
It's not hard like a utility pole.
It's soft and squishy, right?
It's so much and squishy, right?
It's really good.
Rin, you're so squishy and feel great to touch.
I'm pretty squishy, too, because...
Ectoplasm, but...
Pony, pony.
You're getting naughty.
I wonder if you get a different dog
log if you choose tipsy over wasted.
What place is jiggly?
Can you imagine?
I imagine my cursor as like me standing like like I'm
standing over there witnessing all of this behind them and
I'm like just watching You know, just kind of like...
We can't do this outside.
I'm gonna go to auto, though, so I don't have to...
I'm over there like...
They were roommates.
drunk roommates.
Chico,
chico, chico.
Her body is rising.
Oh my god.
You know, I think around this hour there's definitely still
people walking around.
You know,
I think around this hour there's definitely still people
walking around.
so much love me exploded with desire
never do anything you dislike she won't do it anymore don't
hate me Kana...
Yeah?
Kana...
...tomodachi.
My precious friend, huh?
Dear friend.
...
I don't know if you're so cute.
I mean, they're so cute.
I love you.
I love you too.
Oh.
Thank you.
But it's a little bit too.
I'm not going to do that.
Oh, I'm going to do it.
I promise you.
I'm going to make it a promise.
Oh.
They're so cute!
It's not in public, right?
Or maybe?
Or maybe.
Bunny Garden Thruple?
Yeah, aren't I supposed to be like a customer?
Am I just like watching from the distance?
Isn't that the original game is I'm the customer?
And I'm just like standing here like...
Oh, I'm a ghost!
That's a ghost from the bar!
Yeah, say it clearly, Nin-chan.
Watching from the chair.
That's okay too.
Why is she having her say this?
I would die!
I'm already dead!
She's teasing her too much.
Just finished your MGS4 finale VOD.
What an ending.
Is this game similar?
Maybe.
Oh wait, it's time to actually play the game.
Oh my gosh.
When a cast member is drunk, they won't be able to walk
properly.
Control them well and get them home safely.
But in order for a cast...
In order to move a cast member forward, you need to increase
the drunk gauge.
Heat?
When a gauge is half full, you can press the direction
change buttons alternatively to advance forward.
As the drunk gauge gets more full, the cast member's
movements will be harder to control, so make sure to balance
well and move forward.
Oh, okay, wait.
Right rotation.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's panties over there guys.
Okay, okay.
Obstacles.
If your health drops to zero, you won't be able to return
home.
Okay, okay, we gotta get a good score though, right?
Okay.
What's W?
Increase gauge?
Ah, ah!
We turn around!
Turn around, turn around, turn around, turn around!
Turn around!
will have many panties.
The more you pick up, the higher your score will be, so make
sure to grab as many as you can.
By clearing the stage after picking up panties, you will be
able to wear them.
Oh, nice.
Ah, okay.
Uh, what is it, like, left rotation?
Uh, okay.
Keep going.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, no, no.
Please, walk.
Uh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, demde...
Okay We're fine Everything's okay Okay, we're fine.
Everything's alright.
I'm a professional.
This is wasted.
Oh wait, she's turning around for some reason.
Increase the gauge, increase the gauge.
Oh my god, oh my god!
You're okay, you're okay!
Wait!
Oh, shoot.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Turn this way.
Go this way.
No, she's just walking in circles, you guys.
What do I do?
Wait, but I want the rainbow panties!
Let's try this.
Maybe if I do this way.
Okay, here we go.
Ouch!
Wait!
Oh no!
Everything is bad!
Oh my god!
Trouble?
What do you mean trouble?
I'm so thirsty, I can't move anymore.
Why didn't you do that earlier then?
I like how she's drooling.
What happens if you get caught drunk carrying six pairs of
underwear you found?
Yeah, whose underwear is this?
Oh, good job.
Good job, Kana.
Good job.
She narrates everything just like Alan Wake.
She says everything that she's doing exactly like him.
Yeah.
Alan's just really drunk.
Oh, drinking water after alcohol is vital.
Hold the button down to make sure the cast members drink
plenty of water within the time limit.
Wait, is this a second?
If you give them too much water at once, they'll choke.
So make sure to consider resting when drinking.
When the gauge is filled up, you will clear the game.
I'm gonna waterboard her?
Alan has the thermos.
Kana has the pantsu.
Alright, how do I give her water?
Drink!
Oh.
Two, one!
Drink.
Oh, she's choking, she's choking.
You need this- It is- The water!
Oh, she- She's choking!
Sorry.
Ben!
Oh, she- Why are you so bad at drinking water?
Oh.
Sorry, my bad.
I didn't...
This is a jump.
Wait.
She died!
I'm a baby.
This is my first day on Earth and I've never had water
before.
Please understand.
You guys don't...
When you are drinking the water, you're not like...
She was actually was doing her best cat role play.
You know?
Obviously!
You might say she has a drinking problem.
Yeah!
I want to become a shining, a star shining on the silver
screen and television.
That's been an important dream to me ever since I was a
child.
someday I'll make it I'll make it in that world the world
will the world filled with sparkle wait what I didn't expect
this game to have like a storyline I thought it was gonna be
completely different from the original game and just me
walking around, you're wrong.
I never imagined that my dream would come true in such a
way.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm by the police!
No!
Suspect the crime hidden in a newspaper.
Oh, my God.
Inside Akiba's dark alleys.
Wait,
her like, drug voice is so cute.
Wait, her like, drug voice is so cute.
Bani Garden?
Also, didn't she leave in her uniform?
So like, she's gonna have nothing to wear next day.
This is great advertising!
What's a tea game?
The sensor on her eyes.
Oh, twister.
Oh.
T-game is twister.
Is this place legal?
Save that for later.
What do you?
...
Her dream came true!
This is what we call infamy.
Bad end!
Wait, I have to retry!
Oh my gosh, wait, saw the bad end.
Wait, okay, hold on, we can do this.
Oh!
Okay, if I...
If I get the bad end, okay, she gets arrested.
Okay, drink the water.
Oh, I just realized that you have a timer.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're good!
Did she finish?
Mizuwa, how is she?
To clear the round, you have to...
You have to do the mini-game.
She choked a little bit.
It's okay.
Kana night routine has been unlocked.
Kana bonus episode.
Kana swimsuit!
Bonus panties gate.
Nice.
Not the wild zebra.
Oh, my princess green.
Wait, those are cute!
Flower garden orange.
Oh, butterfly rose purple.
Those are in fancy.
Can't see.
Flower garden blue?
Oh!
Whoa!
Love lovely pink!
Ultra rare.
Lucky bonus.
Pure elegant.
Polka dot!
Yeah!
Wait, where's my shima pan?
Panties collector is the achievement I just got.
Wait, where were you this whole time, Rin?
What's her camo index?
I mean the shima pan!
Maybe they're Ocha, Ocha, Ocha, Ocha, O-Double these double,
triple, quadruple, infinity, duple, rare because they're the
bestest ones.
Momi, Momi.
Momi, Momi, Momi.
What are we rubbing?
R-Ri, Ri-chan!
Yes?
Oh.
Oh!
Okay,
so watch it on the plane.
Why are you rubbing my boobs?
You guys are going to learn a lot of Japanese from this
game.
Like a Momi-Momi.
I mean, I'm not going to do anything, right?
Because, you know, that's all.
Momi-Momi, Momi, Momi, Momi, Momi, Momi, Momi, Momi, Momi.
What?
Why she said that about the snacks?
Why did she say that?
Just two girls on the streets of Akiyabawa.
Being silly.
It's my birthday, Julia's happy!
Birthday!
I really hope work isn't monitoring what I'm watching on
their Wi-Fi.
Yeah,
me too.
That's my reaction too.
She doesn't like it.
Maybe she probably likes it.
So now they're Now they've both done this to each other.
Now they've both done this!
Is this what happens at the Ghostmates Cafe?
No!
It's just me, so...
I have nobody...
I have nobody to grab.
Go ahead!
I wanna walk.
I almost want to walk by them and be like, get a room.
No, they're just girlies being girlies.
They're so cute.
Oh, it's just a game?
It's just a game?
It's just for fun.
It is pretty fun.
Wait, so it has a deeper meaning.
Uh-oh.
No,
I think everybody is understanding the situation very...
Very clearly.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean make me quiet?
With your lips?
I thought the OGU game was risky.
This is wild.
They're really going for it.
Docky, docky, docky, docky, docky, docky, docky, docky,
docky, docky.
It's a famous line from the anime.
All she said was, I should say was, I should go back to the
next.
You're going to say that and then leave.
I think she realized.
It's so dramatic.
Imagine just seeing all of that.
A moment of relaxation.
But I have to beat night one, or night one, stage two.
To get to Kan, or to get to Rin.
With night routine.
We're going home, we got this.
Tadaiima!
Wawa-chin, I'm back.
Who's a Wawa-chin?
Kiwawa?
Oh, thank you.
Kiwawa and again?
Her pet dog.
Uh oh.
We gotta go out.
Are you going to like a convenience?
Kiwawa again.
Yeah, she's like a dog.
Okay.
Wait, I'm not the dog.
Wait, so...
Are we going back outside?
We're home!
We like that we're still in our uniform, we haven't changed
at all.
Yeah, I'm so happy, I'm so happy I'm so happy So then, let's
start Yoga?
I'm gonna start yoga Yoga?
Yoga?
Okay, okay, okay Mental men are also good Okay, okay It's
great yoga You know, I'm gonna do it, yoga Yoga?
Yoga?
When you're drunk, yoga?
Downward dog?
What kind of poses?
Thank you so much for the thank you so thank you!
Yoga.
A beginner's pose.
I'll be yoga.
Yoga.
If it's a beginner's pose, then it's okay.
I kind of want to see the bad ends for everybody now.
Okay, everybody's doing yoga.
Oh, what is this music?
Why are you still in your uniform?
And why aren't you in your uniform?
uniform try yoga out for health benefits oh press the button
to stretch your body and charge yoga power if you increase
your yoga power to the max within the time limit what
happens
oh my god this is this is truck couldn't you thought it was
an anime girl but no it's a truck and they had high beams
coming right at you
You did so well!
Your clothes came off!
Yeah,
that's what you call a flashbang, Karina, right?
If that's a truck, Isekai, here I come.
Nice.
Wow,
thank you so much for the good thing.
Oh, no, did we get that as a CG too?
The bath?
So now we lost our clothes outside and now we've exploded
the...
Wow, wow, wow!
Wait, from this angle, doesn't she kind of look like Nimmy?
Doesn't she kind of look like Nimmy with like her hair and
stuff?
The alcohol is completely worn off.
Oh, good.
Oh, wait.
How do I help?
Oh, nice.
That's a lot of steam, you guys.
Good, she's getting nice and sudsy.
Kana shares a voice actor with Maya's top gun from Uma
Musume.
Make of that what you will.
Wait, really?
Things I can't relate to.
Unless it's like my tummy.
Oh,
kind of!
You know, actually my hands are built-in rulers.
You know, I could totally, I could totally check that out
for you.
She's also an OZomi from BA.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah,
that's the other girls' fault.
Yeah, that's the other girls' fault.
What is this?
What is this like self?
What is this conversation she's having with this monologue?
What is she?
It's like, yeah, they touch my boobs when they get drunk,
but I also touch their boobs when they get drunk.
Are their boobs getting bigger because of me?
My friend sent that to me.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to click it, sorry.
My friend sent me a thing the other day, she was just like,
no, she did not say hot dog, but she said, she said, um, she
said that, or so she sent me a, a, it's like a massage
parlor, but it's meant for, it's in Japan, it's meant for
girls to, who want their, their, their chests to be bigger.
She always would complain to me and she would be like, I
want my chest to be bigger!
And...
So she sent this to me and she's like, I'm gonna go to it
next time.
Does it work?
I don't know.
It sounds like a scam.
But you're getting a massage, so...
I guess it would feel nice at least.
Right?
Maybe.
well it's her money so sound she can do whatever she wants
wait hold on let me see what it was hold on let me see what
it was for anybody curious
she said she said I'm interested and I said you should and
she said I mean massage by pretty ladies and boobers get one
bow win-win even if it doesn't work it could be a good a
breast cancer checkup I don't think they'll be looking for
that Minto there's a dojinchi about that I'm sure it's
called tiara well on let's see but it's kind of expensive I
feel oh wait this is for one month or and they even show the
results and i'm like they show like a girl she can't fill
out her bra and this is before and then after she can fill
out the bra so i don't know i feel how else would you do
that otherwise it's the same bra
are you sure she didn't get confused by the dojin she title
no this is the one it's real it's on hot pepper beauty so So
it's gotta be real.
Tiara, the boob massage place, parlor.
Anyway.
Sounds legit.
I know, and if you're getting massaged by a pretty lady,
then I mean, I understand my friend.
Yeah.
Does everyone prefer them baker?
I say,
any size is a prize.
I'm losing it to Boobers get womboed.
That's what she said.
Skincare!
Oh, yeah.
I do every day.
I also got a new skincare set.
Oh my gosh, it came in the mail!
Don't let them massage your feet.
Will my feet get bigger?
That is justice.
I take so too.
I'd love to see you.
I think we're gonna have another mini game everybody.
Focus on your face.
I've helped people with like skincare routine.
So if you're like, you know, if you're like, oh my gosh, I'm
afraid of being given like a seven step care routine that
I'm never gonna remember how to do anything with don't you
worry I know how to make them also very simple so you know
if you are like I just want something kind of to just be a
little like nice but to make myself my skin look nicer but
not a lot of work then I can help you with that too hmm yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's try skincare to make your skin soft
shake the toner and and milky gauge are wait, shake until
the toner and milky gauge are maxed out.
After the gauge is maxed out, press the button to fire!
Launch the toner and milk toner.
Why are we launching two toners?
But there is, but milky toner is like a thing, so um...
skincare time!
YouTube!
It's skincare!
We knew exactly what was gonna happen, but...
Sludgeier?
Eww!
Push-ups and massage can increase blood flow temporarily to
make things bigger.
By guys, I have arn-gym pumps.
Arn-gym pumps.
Okay, time for the sleeping mini-gim.
Oh, yes, me!
I love that Min loves this.
I love it too.
Everyone, 07, this body is surviving.
It will!
It's fine!
Can you confirm that that's the proper way to...
Well, okay, well...
It's not incorrect.
You do gotta get it on there.
I've been doing my Korean skincare wrong the whole time.
I've let down my home country.
I know, we should all take lessons from Mary Bunny Garden.
Clearly.
We walk with a bounce and step has been unlocked.
Ring gaming!
Yippee!
What is this one, though?
A moment of relaxation.
I'm scared.
Rip Vod.
Will this be in the skincare tutorial?
But you know, now that I think about it, a lot of my
skincare is kind of like white like that, you know, or like
kind of...
Like that consistency.
I like to watch skincare videos every now and then too.
Oh yeah!
Like actual ones.
Yeah.
Me too.
review skincare.
Let's finish this Kano one.
Oh, bonus episode.
That's what this is.
Fine.
Oh.
What is here?
Are they censoring the crack?
I can't even...
I think her shorts are down.
Yeah, but they're not so...
It's literally just her booty crack right there.
Girl must be a plumber.
It's really bright in her room, you know?
Oh, just kidding.
It's night time?
Yeah, the peace!
The peace!
Beaches, beaches, beaches, beaches, beaches, beaches.
Beaches, beaches, beaches, beaches.
It's okay, you can fall asleep, kinda.
It's okay!
Oh, Wawa is a cat!
Not a dog.
Maybe?
Or it's a dog that uses a litter box?
These pajamas are so cute, I wish I could see more of them.
There has to be an uncensored version.
Maybe it's like a bonus CD or something.
Right!
Or a human.
Yeah, a human trained to use a litter box.
And then a cat trained to use the toilet.
It's in the settings.
I checked though, I checked the...
I checked... I clicked off sensitivity mode, so...
I'm not in streaming mode.
I clicked... I already changed it.
I don't think it would detect the OB errors.
The uncensored version is on the L side.
Oh wait, really?
I don't think it's R18 though.
This is not enough to be... I could see a part of her...
The top.
I don't think it's... I think they're just... I don't know.
What is it?
This girl is a yapper.
She should stream.
Just a little bit, huh?
She's... Oh.
She's chilling?
Ah?
Uri-yari-kuchi-miru-no?
Aw, it's not.
Sensitive mode options is the opposite of what you think it
does.
Wait, so I turned it on on accident?
Oh, no!
Oh, yeah.
She's talking about the manju everybody.
Yummy, yummy.
I thought it was gonna be like one of those roll, like the
roll sushi or something.
You know?
Red.
Oh, anko!
Red bean paste.
Oh, yummy.
Oh, that's like such a...
I think that's like a difficult thing to translate.
Because like in the Japanese, it would say like...
Like she's, you know, making a sexy noise.
But in English, they have to translate it to red.
So it doesn't really make any sense.
Because anko is red bean.
So it's like kind of funny.
You have the chance to write your...
Me too, I love RARs.
I love RARs.
What could be the minigame here?
Oh,
we touch them.
Imagine sleeping next to her.
She would just say the whole...
Everything.
She would have a whole conversation in her sleep.
You would be like...
Do you think you could...
She was just yapping.
So she's dreaming about food and also...
And
also...
Also about her cat, probably.
Right.
Or...
She's pretending she's a cat and is saying, you can touch my
tail.
Because it's a special players.
Oh!
Maybe she's dreaming of Mito.
A bunny girl does dream of ghost maid.
Not so
rough.
It's her tail.
It's got...
Or her bunny ears or something.
It's gotta be.
It's gotta be like she's pretending she's a carrot.
Or she's...
It's gotta be.
Ears.
No, too sensitive.
Too sensitive.
Ears are too sensitive.
But like about like, but the bunny ear.
Not actual ear.
Ah!
See, I told you!
I called it.
I called it!
I like
her pajamas very much though.
They're very cute.
It reminds me of a bunny character that I actually like and
I own some stuff with the bunny character.
And then I went to a place and they were selling, they had a
collaboration with that artist and the bunny character.
And I was really excited.
Except the pajamas were like over a hundred dollars.
So I didn't get them.
Kind of the type of person to read out the whole B-movie
script in her sleep.
So true!
Unicode clam?
No.
Different.
I think she wants to touch fluffy tail.
They were really nice quality, but...
Bushi touch.
Something that is hard but squishy.
I still think it's a tail.
Wait, no, you can't fall asleep after that, Kana.
Kana, we need explanation!
It's no-money-kone-kone-chate-tote-y-o.
Oh, what's
that?
Big cursor, get out of there.
Hi!
Oh, look how cute her face is, though.
Look at her little smile!
Wait, it's so cute!
Wait, what was it, Kana?
Kana, what was it?
Sophie!
Chittle man, welcome to Mamu Shepda.
Wait, there was literally no...
We didn't do anything.
We cleared it.
I win by doing nothing.
Okay, before we go to night two, let's do really...
Oysu!
Wait!
We are- I think though our costume we can still get other...
How do I equip?
Oh, like that.
Okay.
Breeze!
Oh, she doesn't- wait.
Uh...
Wait, Breeze!
Oh no!
She has a pencil skirt!
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, we can do this, we can do this, we can do
this, we can do this, we can do this, we can do this, we can
do this, we can do this, we can do this, we can do this, oh,
why is she crying, why are you crying,
freeze, wait, but if it's It doesn't matter.
Akashachi, thank you so much for the 10 gifts, and thank
you!
So sensitive mode means...
Whoa!
One start.
Come on, Juna, you can see everything!
Oh, ow!
Whoa, it looks like she's holding it up.
Oh my god.
Now we're talking.
Pure, elegant.
Oh my gosh, right?
They're so cute.
The zebra ones are hilarious.
I'm curious.
Poca Daughter is so cute!
Love, love, love.
I
like the bunny in the farm.
Wait, so...
Rin, we can never...
We can never do the breeze.
We'll just know.
My princess.
Yeah.
Minto girl.
Vlad gonna get nuked.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine!
Oh, oops.
It's let's do Rhin's route.
Gaming...
Gaming night of Siwat and Smile.
Siwat.
Office.
Wasted.
We get the wasted again.
I think we were good.
I think we were really good.
I'm sweaty.
Oh,
it does say VDX there, so what is supposed to be you there?
She's so cute.
I love Rin.
She's my favorite.
She's so cute.
She's also anime otaku, so I love her.
Our hair is similar.
She also forgot to change.
I have the Rin pop-up parent figure!
It's kind of crazy that this Kurei game popped off the way
it did and like even got merged.
It's kind of rare for their games.
What's wrong?
Are you going to try and fail Rin too?
Yeah, yeah.
I want a bunny girl out with...
No, you're not such a cute one.
She drew such a really good See, she's gonna go binge anime.
She wants to move her body, yadi, yadi.
Let's dance!
A super special move?
What does that mean?
What is a hair root catastrophe?
Uh-oh, she gonna...
She gonna...
...
Pulling someone's hair?
She's going to swat.
Yeah.
I'm swatting.
I do wonder what time it is.
Like, what time does the bunny garden close, you know?
1 a.m?
No, I can't...
11 p.m.
maybe?
There's nothing open.
...
She's falling asleep in the streets?
Look how cute she is though.
It's okay, you can fall asleep in the streets as a treat.
...
Shibuya meltdown.
Shibuya meltdown in Akibo.
...
Well, these places don't really...
Actually, I don't know.
Because I can't go to these places.
They usually don't let girls go as like customers.
But I feel like 11pm is probably normal.
It's like when most mid cafes close is 11.
And I wouldn't count this as like a hostess club.
You know, so...
Yeah, gotta be...
Usually things close before last train.
Because last train is like, depending on what line it is,
it's like 11 to 1 a.m.
is depending on the train, so...
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, where am I going?
Yep, yep, yep, yep, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
nope, nope, nope.
You're fine, you're fine.
Nope, that way.
That way.
Yeah, yeah.
Get the, so true.
That way.
We got the Andes.
Oh my god, you tapped them.
that it's fine how does that hurt ghetto build the heat what
does the heat do oh whoa oh it makes her it makes her crazy
are am i going through the store oh wait there's golden
panties makes things hacked oh my god wait which way am i
going oh my god i can't see anything game game please game
game Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god,
oh god!
Wait, I have to take...
Ouch!
I have to take damage!
To get them!
Okay, we gotta go inside, I think.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
We're fine!
You can pick up healing items and panties in the convenience
store.
into a shelf will cause.
What will it cause?
I wish I could see anything.
Oh, so sorry.
Excuse me.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Excuse me.
I can't...
Oh, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Legendary?
I can't see anything, you guys.
Wait, there's more!
We must...
We have to destroy everything!
Oh my god, I can't see it!
Ah!
When the drunk gauge is full and a few seconds past, the
gauge will overheat the cast member will become dizzy and
pass out!
I passed out.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
Keep knocking it over.
Yeah.
Lucky.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah!
Is this also?
No, this is normal.
Where do I go then?
Okay.
This way?
Ouch!
Okay, I think I need to go through this way.
It seems.
Ow!
This way, this way.
Nope.
Oh, yes?
No, never mind.
Oh, this way!
Oh my god, I'm running into everything.
I'm running into everything.
This one.
Ouch!
It's fine!
It's fine, everyone!
Wait, we might lose our clothes, though, when we...
Wait, does that mean we're gonna lose our clothes?
Is that what that means?
Ouch.
See that little clothing thing right there?
Oh my god, I can't stop running into everything, you guys.
Wait, there's a healing item!
There's a healing...
Right there, right there.
Oh, did I die?
I think I just died.
No!
Please no, don't make me redo it from the start!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, well we learned.
Whoa, wait, but...
Oh, oh, my panties are still picked up though.
That's good, that's good.
Wait, we could get even more.
The store is restocked.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
No, no, no, turn around, turn around.
This way.
Yeah, you're fine.
You're fine.
You're okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Look at her go.
She's... Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Everything's okay.
You're okay.
I can't see it.
Okay.
Oh, this way.
This way.
Yep.
Turn around.
I can't get it through the door.
No!
All right.
This way.
Oh, we're almost inside.
Oh my god.
No!
Please!
Just go inside!
Doors!
She's allergic!
She's a vampire!
She has to be invited first or something!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna let the heat...
Oh my god.
Wait, are we gonna lose clothes?
It really is, Senran Kagura!
Okay, all right.
That way.
There.
Keep going forward.
There we go.
Yeah, keep going there.
Yeah.
There we go.
Keep going forward.
Yeah.
And forward.
Ah!
We made it!
Okay, now we can destroy everything that we want.
Oh, I can't gauge.
Yes!
Oh!
Okay, it seems like all of the panties are already gone.
That's okay.
Okay.
Okay, the camera is the final blast, honestly.
Okay, all right.
All right.
Oh, no, no, no, it's okay.
Don't, don't cry.
Don't cry.
Ow!
We're fine, everybody.
Okay, this way.
This way.
Keep going.
Here.
Okay, keep going, keep going.
Yeah.
This way, this way.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Oh, keep going.
Keep going!
I think you guys were gonna have to abandon that legendary
one over there.
Wait, why'd you turn around?
Don't do that.
Go this way.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh no, oh no!
Oh no, please!
Where's the goal?
This is impossible, everybody.
This might be impossible.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, come on.
You're fine.
Everything's okay.
Please.
See?
Oh, I thought that was health.
It's just...
Oh my god.
Guys, we might explode again.
What?
This is like the second stage!
No, stinking way!
Oh my god.
Okay, Zenyoku dash, yeah!
No, no, no, maybe not.
Zenyoku dash.
Maybe slow and steady wins the race, like a turtle.
And we're not gonna go into...
We're not gonna go into the...
Oh my god.
Ouch.
We're not gonna go into the conveni.
Ouch, ouch.
We're okay.
We're not gonna explode.
We might explode.
Actually, that one's like...
What?
Oh my god.
If you hit certain things, sometimes panties.
fly out.
Why are the barrels of nitroglycerate in Japan?
In the alleyways of Akihabara!
You guys they tell you about like you know, chikan or you
know, they tell you to be afraid of people but they never
tell you about the barrels.
The barrel, the exploding barrels.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, we're doing, we're already doing a little bit better
though.
We're already, we're already doing a little bit better.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Good job, good job.
It's okay, it's okay.
Honestly, I almost want to like just ram through these boxes
here.
These ones right here.
Shortcut, shortcut!
Okay.
There's the goal!
No!
Please, please!
The goal!
Oh my god.
I kind of wish that we had exploded into the goal.
It would have been really great.
Alright, time to drink water, everybody!
Take a sip when she dies, okay?
It's a little drinking but with water.
Yeah, there's yeah, there's there's there's.
You have water.
But if she gets waterboarded, so do you, okay?
That's literally the rules.
If she waterboards, so do you too, okay?
Just dump it all in your mouth, all right?
I only have run.
No!
Let's see how it looks with the sensor off.
Oh wait, you're right.
Wait, is she also?
Are her clothes gonna be torn?
You think?
I did see though that if you play this game on the Switch,
the colors are censored.
If you...
Yeah, we'll get the bad end first.
But luckily I'm playing on Steam!
Itadakimasu!
She's such a drunk girl.
See rabbit ears?
Where's the rest of the traditional outfit?
Tray of drinks?
I'm a bunny.
Alright.
Let's drink, guys.
Let's do it.
We got this.
Except not at first, because I want the bad end.
Oh, her clothes are torn.
A little sip as a treat.
We're failing this one on purpose, guys, so we can see the
bad end, because it's funny.
Yaru's supremacy.
Yeah!
Okay.
on switch it's like getting skincare from shrek let's see
what happens oh my god wait no that's so embarrassing oh
wait are we in jail is this our one call you think oh no oh
no Oh no.
Oh no.
No.
Do they give one phone call in Japan?
I don't know.
I think it's a similar thing as before where we appear on
the TV.
Oh, wait a second.
It's the same exact...
It's the same exact picture!
They just swapped the heads!
But...
Aw, me!
I don't want to church to crypto, I feel like we got
cheated, you guys.
The music is so funny though, it's so sad.
Okay, I'm gonna skip it then.
Oh, well let me skip, just kidding.
Yeah, we got scammed, for real!
Dang.
That's fun.
Dame, dame, dame, dame, dame.
Dame, dame, dame.
Almost Western, the music?
I don't know.
Go on.
That's a totally legal business.
Star!
Are you proud of me, ma'am?
I'm on the telly.
Not
the respect.
All respect lost.
No, I'm absolutely not drinking too much.
I'm sorry!
Bad end.
Okay, we gotta try the...
We gotta redo the minigame.
I'll do it properly this time.
Nodogu...
...kawaita zhe...
Okay.
I don't...
How was I supposed to do that?
I think I just hold it, right?
Drink!
Drink, drink, drink, drink!
Hydrate!
Oh, sorry.
Too much hydrate!
Hydrate!
Thank you so much for the fine gift in!
What a face.
I got an A still!
Let's go!
Even though...
Even though I took so much damage, Woohoo!
Whoa, my abs.
Look at her abs.
Whoa!
Bonus panties.
Not the zebra again.
Wait, those are so cute!
Yes, yes, yes!
Ooh, simple we like.
Calvin Clay!
Wait, why is that?
This is spelled with a K here and a Q there.
Localizers, please explain.
Cow Ben Klein!
Whoa!
Hydra Angel, that's my favorite flower!
Pure, elegant.
Holy cow!
How are these a one star?
Excuse me?
Oh!
Royal Maid!
Dang, we got a lot.
Waterfly.
Royal Maid.
Low rise.
Where are the strawberry ones?
They're so cute!
Yes!
But they got the Shima Pan.
Military girl.
Strawberry pink.
Holy moly.
She...
She go to the Geshe and plays...
She plays GDR.
In her heels and in her...
In her body uniform.
Cha-Lan!
La-Lan!
What's our fateful encounter?
Wait, what happened?
Oh,
she just wanted to go play?
Okay.
You know one thing that kind of takes me out of her being a
gyaru are her nails.
They're just not done up enough.
They're not like long enough and don't have enough deco on
them.
The nails need to be way more flashy.
Duh.
Is that physique attainable?
Probably.
If you play her route in the game, she actually isn't a
gyaru.
Oh, really?
I didn't finish Bunny Girl.
Or a bunny guard in the original.
She just is...
Gengi cute girl?
But even still, girls in Japan are very serious about their
nails.
I feel like even still she would have much flashier nails,
even if she's...
Not all Gyaru have like super...
Or rather, you don't have to be a Gyaru to have the flashier
nails.
She's dorky who likes games and stuff.
Yeah, I remember that though.
That's why I liked her as my favorite.
But that doesn't mean anything.
I mean, do you watch a Biscuit doll too?
She has really fancy nails.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wait,
why are you...
Wait, why are we taking off our clothes?
I don't think it's the clothes that are heavy.
I think it's the thing that the clothes are...
What?
Wait, what?
Weighted clothing.
She's rock-ly.
What?
Your panties and your bra weigh 5 kilograms!
Oh, okay.
I guess that's true.
Helps with aerodynamics.
I always play on the dance pad naked.
People are watching.
Wait, so if the game center is even open, what time is it?
What is this cowboy music playing?
The cow...
Wait, what's happening?
The cowboy...
Wait, she's taking off her clothes!
Oh my gosh, she really is gonna be on the news.
Never go outside, everybody.
Let's try the night routine again.
Let's try it.
We don't need to do the relaxation.
She's pooped.
Good sweat.
good everybody but after this we can try her second night
that's what I'm really curious about I want to keep trying
the harder levels especially because now we know we can
explode what else will there be I wonder if there will be
like animals that try to attack us too
Why is she so violent to me?
Kruna, thank you so much for the time, Kete!
I just said not, Ducky.
Why you said a poop?
Oh, because she's pooped, yeah.
She's pooped!
You guys, my cat pooped in the letterbox and the poop was
sticking straight up.
How does it do that?
Yeah!
What's a fiber?
That's how I feel about my maid cafe too though when I look
at my decorations and stuff I'm like Anime paradise
Oh no I forgot about the yoga
Bad skills.
Everybody do yoga.
It's good for you.
Yoga, yoga.
Yeah, wait.
We're going to yoga without the...
But our clothes.
Oh my god, I'm still busted up!
No!
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, it's just the patties.
The headlights, you guys!
Oh my god, the truck is incoming!
It's not a pair of boobs, it's a truck!
Get out of the road!
What are you doing?
Just standing there!
You're gonna get hit by the truck!
This ghost swag ectoplasm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good day.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
What a time to be a deer in the headlights!
We're gonna warp?
Might I ask what this game be about?
Do you know Bunny Garden, the original?
Trash boy, welcome back!
Okay, time for bath, baby.
Without the lie, wait, wait, hide.
Wow, very, very, it's nice and sunny, everybody.
I also giggle while I'm in the...
Wait, what do you mean you're not good at washing your
armpits?
How are you, how is it?
Oh, because it's ticklish.
Also, why do you have soap in your hair?
Yeah,
I was gonna say.
Pat's truck good.
She's got the three-in-one.
Oh no!
Your pink will wash out!
Pink is a hard color to maintain.
Training?
Oh, she's gonna tickle herself?
She's a liar, you can't tickle yourself.
She's just trying to get you to touch her.
Run me though, her intentions are not pure!
She's scamming me!
I laugh
in the shower too.
I laugh in the shower too.
Which area are we doing next?
You're already explaining your actions, please, in great
detail.
If you're going to say every step by step, you'll have to
tell me where you're touching next.
It's only the reals.
She's so ticklish.
Wait, is it really true that you can't tickle yourself?
Is it true?
I'm going to try tickling my foot.
It does kind of tickle, though.
But my armpits are not ticklish at all.
That's sensitive area.
I guess...
You know that.
You know.
the thing where someone grabs your knee like the the points
on each side of your knee like if i grab that part it's not
ticklish but if someone else were to grab that part you know
what i mean it's ticklish
yeah that part is ticklish no you guys know
yeah it's tickles when someone else tickles yeah yeah yeah
the So the side, each, like on each side of your knee.
Like just not, like not on the bone, just a little bit above
it, you know?
If you do it yourself, it's not going to be ticklish.
But if somebody else does it, it's ticklish.
Have you never had siblings that would do that?
Scientifically, only ticklish spot is the roof of your mouth
using your tongue.
Oh, it is.
It's ticklish!
Wait, how is that possible?
Now I have to scratch it.
Oh my god, it's ticklish.
I have to scratch it with my tongue.
What?
That's craziness.
New fear unlocked.
We're gonna try Aare.
That's a try.
Skincare?
Yeah!
Oh no.
Do you have any skincare routines we recommend for people
with eczema?
I once possessed somebody with eczema, so I got pretty used
to it.
I will do a skincare stream.
Do a skincare stream.
My dad was only ticklish on the side of his big toes.
I kind of feel it though.
Mm.
Oh my god, girl math.
Girl math!
I can't tickle the roof of my mouth with my own tongue.
Maybe you can tickle it with yours.
You guys are freaks!
Freaks and perverts!
Get your hands out of the gutter, you freaks and perverts!
Oh, uh, shake, shake, shake, shake, shake.
Shake, shake, shake, shake, shake.
Splash!
Shake, shake, shake, shake, shake, shake, shake, shake.
And splash!
This is the person who chose this game.
Shake, shake, shake, shake your skincare, shake your
skincare.
That better look at your favorite Sephora.
Don't hold up the mirror to me!
Right in the kisser.
It's skincare, everybody.
Skincare.
Yeah, we're doing it.
the slugging method.
It's the slugging method.
That's a real thing, you guys.
It's a real thing.
No, not tomorrow.
Oh, yes, no, no, no.
Snail musin.
It's true.
All right.
pool on the streets i love skin care the bonds between cats
oh wait wait there might actually be animals oh no no no
let's do minyokas
okay office wait what about the cats Let's do worsted.
We'll do all girls.
I want to keep doing Rin, but we'll do all girls so that
everybody can get their favorite girl in.
Pion, pion, pion, pion, pion, pion, pion, pion.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
She's talking about me?
I'm so cute.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yes, you are mean though?
Yes,
you are mean though.
Kana's My... my extra pleasure would melt.
Take her.
Oh, mochi-cairie!
What are you a dog?
A dog?
A walk every day?
Yeah, we can't sleep.
All these girls yapping their sleep.
I don't think you'll ever get any...
They would like...
They would... their dreams would be used together and they
would just have conversations.
They would just have conversations in their sleep probably.
Aww, awry, awry!
Kiko, Eiko, Eiko!
Let's go home.
Kyoon!
Oh, a...
Aheadishikawaigari.
It's a good quinoa and a bad shiwa...
I don't think you should iron that.
I think you should use a steamer on it probably.
Kha 'ai, K'ai, K'ai, K'ai.
Where in the wild wish?
I can't Where in the wild wish?
I can't
Oh, she's a sister, that's right.
Moika?
I remember that.
Yeah, yeah.
So, yeah.
So, Moika, too.
Yeah.
Moika comes too.
Mm.
Oh my god, the family!
They're problematic to watch in the office.
We love you a bit more.
Cypher!
Good luck with work!
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Oh, oh geez.
Wait, is there anything behind me?
Ouch.
A wall?
Okay.
This way?
This way, Miyuka?
Oh, Miyuka.
Wait in front of you.
Yata!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, gosh, there's a 24-hour camera here.
That's not the...
They're gonna see me.
They're gonna...
Oh!
Okay, forward.
Forward.
Yes.
I wonder where this is supposed to be.
Is that gold?
That's not rainbow.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Wait, oh, it won't let me.
I was gonna say it won't let us go into the road.
Okay.
Alright guys, nice.
Come on.
I see a rainbow over there.
I see it, I see it.
Wait, there's people!
What are those?
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Wait, there's people.
Wait, there's...
Did she just say it smells good?
So we know the smell now.
What the- Yeah, yeah, lucky, lucky.
Oh my god, the bird is attacking me!
Oh my god, oh my god, the bird!
Oh my god!
Okay, we can make it through this one.
I believe, I believe, I believe, I believe.
Yes!
We're too good.
We're too good, guys.
RJ boy, we got it.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, it
was a necessary tank, we're tanking it.
Why are the birds attacking me?
Wait, we can go into the...
Okay, yeah, yeah, nice, nice.
Oh shoot, okay, don't get hit by the car.
The headlines, everybody, I told you, they were real.
Yatta!
Destruction!
Alfred Hitchcock, hidden kid in inspiration.
I don't think it's so hidden.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nice!
Uh...
Wait.
Okay.
Alright, don't get hit by the car, everybody.
Oh my god, wait.
The car is on fire!
Wait!
Uh, how am I supposed to get through?
Wait, uh...
Excuse me!
Sorry!
Look!
Oh my god!
Guys, you think I'm gonna be able to beat this game?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Why is she just sitting?
Like newbie.
Oh my god.
I killed that guy.
I think so!
Oh my god!
No, no, no, the birds!
Why are there birds attacking me?
There's gotta be another way!
Oh my god, where?
There's no goal in sight!
Oh my god, the bird!
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
Get out of here, you nasty creature!
Oh!
Oh, chill, chill, chill.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
No, no, no, no, no.
No don't don't don't explode.
Don't explode.
Okay.
All right.
Oh god.
It's okay.
You're fine.
Okay.
Oh, this way, this way, this way, this way.
This way, this way.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh no.
No!
Guys, it's so over.
It's so over.
How am I supposed to get around this?
I didn't even know!
How are you supposed to get around this?
She's dead!
You have to move away.
from the secondary explosion.
Oh, I'm sorry, there's realism in this game.
I'm sorry, I didn't, I'm sorry, I should have expected that
the car would do a second explosion because that's what
would happen in real life if the car is on fire, you know?
Bunny Cemetery.
No way.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't...
I feel like I'm still learning the controls of this you know
so we like turn up the heat and then we basically oh but
then she goes crazy mode like this oh my god miyuka please
miyuka you're okay oh no it's too hard to control when the
heat is too high oh my god i can't control her she's a she's
a rogue bunny she's gone rogue oh my god oh my god oh my god
i've seen so many cars on fire I've never seen them explode.
Kana...
Oh, she's saying Kana has a...
It smells good.
Okay.
The bird.
Oh my god.
Oh, this game is so hard.
Wait, this game is actual rage game.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
No, out!
Oh my god.
Oh, you take damage while you lay on the ground.
Cameraman?
Cameraman's not me!
Oh my god, there's a bird attacking me!
Please!
Let me out!
Oh my god.
Please leave.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I wonder if I...
Oh, I don't think I can knock those over.
Wait!
If I can get across that and then also avoid the barrel?
Oh my god, that's a shortcut.
What?
I don't think I can make it though.
That's tiny.
Why am I spinning in circles?
Please, Miyuka!
I need you to go straight.
Oh my god, that's tiny.
There's no way.
If I fall...
I die.
Wow!
Look at them, chakes!
I'm progressing!
I blame heat mode.
I blame it.
I want to grab those cheeks.
I see the goal!
Oh my gosh, no way.
Hold on, I'm going to try something since we're here.
Please just go forward.
Can I go through here?
No, okay.
You can't.
This way?
That's why?
That's why Mewka's my fave.
I think, I feel like they all have the same character model.
I'm not gonna lie.
I could be wrong, but like, it feels like they all have
this...
Oh my god, please stop going in circles.
Just with their heads replaced.
There's like no variety.
in their booby size at all.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, please.
Please!
Oh, the wall!
Oh my god, we're taking so much mega damage!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Bird, problem, gone.
We need you to not go in circles.
Ouch.
I need you to go forward.
And like...
Okay.
Avoid the explosion.
No, no, no, please.
Please don't fall in!
Please!
Okay, okay, we're so close.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, turn around!
Okay, come on, come on, come on.
No, please!
Oh my God!
Ah, ha!
Okay, go forward, go forward.
Okay.
Okay, oh shoot.
Oh my God.
Ouch.
That took so much damage.
Oh my god.
Oh, we gotta get into the...
Okay, if we get in there...
We can just, uh...
Get some health.
Yeah, we'll get health in here.
Nice.
Yeah, gumbare, wattashi.
We can do this?
Okay.
Alright, let's hold off, hold off a second.
Yeah, yeah, the car's gonna come back.
The car's gonna come back.
Okay, there we go.
Now go.
Go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go!
Wait, just stay here.
No!
Wait, we gotta get out of here!
We gotta get out of here!
Don't explode.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's gonna explode again?
Wait.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Okay.
Progress!
Progress, everybody!
Oh my god.
We're not even gonna try and get the Golden Undies.
We're just gonna keep going forward.
Oh my god.
Somebody died but honestly...
Oh, okay.
We gotta go this way.
Okay.
Somebody died but can we really blame ourselves here?
Ouch.
Uh, we're gonna tank it.
Thank you.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah.
I bet there's people really serious about this game though.
Ouch.
Oh my god, another bird!
No,
no, no, no, no, no, no!
Alright, keep going.
Keep going.
This way.
Dame.
Oh, this way?
This way?
Okay.
Yeah, the bunny guard attorneys are going crazy, everybody.
Watch out for explosion.
Yeah.
There we go.
Watch out for explosion?
Yeah.
The goal!
Oh my god, you guys, we made it.
Come on!
Miuka!
We made it!
Oh my god, I'm not gonna do...
I'm not gonna fail at this time, because we already...
Oh!
Unless you want to see what she looks like.
But it's the same thing.
We got like no special ones.
The music we want to see.
Oh, it was different.
Like Rin was like, don't watch mama.
And then, and then Kana was like, I want to be an actress.
Okay, we'll do it then.
We'll do it.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Okay, I'll do it for you guys.
I'll do it for you guys.
So, aggressive, huh?
Who she talking to right now?
They just talk to themselves.
Like a lot.
Like...
They're just...
They're just yappers.
Girls are just always...
They have like a...
invisible audience.
She's talking to me.
No?
Oh no, the sorrow
She's talking to me She's talking to me She's talking to me
That's crazy.
Alright, I'll fail it, I'll fail it for you guys.
So that we can see what the bad end looks like.
The jump cut is so funny to me.
Worst drinker ever award.
No, please!
No, please.
Uh-oh.
Next, Alan Wakestream will be Alan and a bunny geeky crew
collecting menus giving changes while drunk.
Please, God, no.
She blacked out.
I'm trying to black out.
Uh-huh.
Is she gonna, okay, so she, so first we have the first
person with, oh yeah, she's gonna see her own television
program.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Wait, did Moika see it?
Oh my god, no.
A proper adult who does not cause a murder.
Well, to be fair, though, that guy was going to murder us.
We could claim it was self-defense.
I think we can claim self-defense.
Kill or be killed in the bunny garden world.
Yeah, she does look smaller, no?
Bunny garden?
Maybe it is different.
Huh?
Handsumo!
I want to do a handsumo.
Binary Ghost, thank you for this, everyone.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Oh,
hand sumo is forbidden outdoors, everybody.
I think the police officer has the same lines every time.
I just got her to record once.
I thought I gave you water!
What?
Sad music is so funny.
It's just, it seems so like a, it sounds like disappointment
in a musical form.
Was it about dream, Yuka?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
No.
She's coping.
Okay, let's read, let's do it now for real.
Okay.
Go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go.
Go-go-go-go-go.
Don't choke.
Oh, she choked.
I do it every time around here.
Go-go-go-go-go-go.
You can make it!
No!
Oh my god, I missed it again.
No stinking way.
Oh my god, I was right at the end.
Please!
I think we can skip it.
though oh whoops i always forget to press next there okay
skip skip skip skip skip
guys i'm so bad at drinking i don't know maybe it would help
if you like didn't stick your tongue out you know
okay all right
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Good.
I don't...
Do you forget how to drink water if you are...
You're so drunk.
Oh, we did get two super wares, okay?
Wowie, what a swimsuit.
Let's see what we got.
Cute!
The rabbit ones are so cute!
Ooh, standard.
Okay, low rise for real.
Oh, no, we got a dupes, uh, three star.
Ooh, my princess.
Gothic devil!
That's good.
Lifeline green.
It's okay.
Calvin Klein.
I mean, Klayn.
Sorry.
Shimapan!
Oh, but we did get a...
Oh.
Another seriously same...
We got two of the military ones the same time.
Miyuka, are you okay?
Repeat!
Nyanyo.
So cute!
Cute!
There's the cat.
I did wonder if we would get attacked by animals.
We did get attacked by the bird.
Oh my god.
Cute!
Nyan-Yan-Yan's secret place.
Blue.
Come on, come, come, come, come, Nyan-Yan.
Nyan-Yan.
Cute!
Nyan-Yan!
Why is the cat making that face?
He's like, he's like, no, I've had enough.
Like his hand is out and everything.
He's like,
he's like, no thank you, I'm full.
No,
thank you.
Oh my god!
Wait, he actually is pushing her away!
Look at him, he's so cute!
Wait, that's actually so funny!
I didn't know it was a girl.
It's so funny.
She's gonna get scratched.
Got scratched for you, boy.
Oh my gosh, she's a bad girl.
I don't think I was be sniffing a stray cat.
I'm not gonna lie.
Like I would pet a stray cat probably because I can't help
myself but I don't think I would be sticking my nose in
there for like that.
Understandable.
Deep reflection.
Nekosui no She got that Toxma Plasmosis.
Yeah, yeah, the thing with the cats.
I think I have that.
I think I have it.
Probably.
My cat sleeps next to my head, so...
Wait,
wait, wait, us?
She's talking to me!
She's talking to us!
She's talking to eyes!
Don't fall for dog propaganda.
So true, I love cats didn't match.
Don't cry, don't cry.
Why are you crying?
What's the last time you caught someone in Ninkumpu?
Right now?
Last year?
Last Tuesday?
Just yesterday?
Mint Kampu.
But,
Moeka's and Onei-chan's are important roles.
Thank you, Miu-Ka-chan!
I want to be doated on by an older sibling.
But sadly, my sister does not.
What's the point of having an older sibling if they do not
do it on you?
Let's see.
I could do the night routine as we've done.
We'll do the night routine since we did it with all three of
everybody.
And then we could do the second stage.
She wants to play Goo Goo Babies.
I don't know what that means.
But one time I wanted to play Barbies with my sister and she
wouldn't.
So I ran up and I bit her.
And then she started to bleed.
I got a fang after all.
I said, play barbies with me.
She wouldn't play barbies with me.
I'm an older sibling.
I farted on my younger siblings.
No wonder she doesn't pamper you.
I'm an older sibling, I farted on my younger siblings.
Have fun with the customers.
Yeah, you should.
Can ghosts have rabies?
Probably not.
You might get a Minto virus though if I bite you.
Come on, Miu Kai, you gotta try harder.
You gotta try harder.
Oh, no, the yoga.
All right, yoga time, everybody.
Yoga, yoga, yoga, yoga, yoga.
Can I be patient zero?
I'll do the Barbie whatever after.
It's not that whatever.
It's very important business.
They all do the same.
yoga though oh my god can you imagine going into work the
next day and just being like sorry i'm so sorry that wait i
wonder if you don't succeed in yoga what happens wait
there's a camera control oh oh
You guys, wake up!
You guys, get out of the room!
That's not boobs!
That's a truck coming your way!
With high beams on!
Quit being a deer in the headlights!
closer!
You have to move!
And you died.
Do these girls walk?
How is that breaking a sweat, huh?
Rude to leave your high beams on for incoming cars.
That's true.
That is very true.
Remove all headlights from cars.
Reminds a scene from Dumb and Dumber movies.
I've never seen that.
She's smelly!
The lights has placed at 3003135.
It should say 8008135.
Was that one taken?
How old is Moeka?
She can't wash herself.
As long as you do your skincare because your skin will get
dry like that.
Double bath.
Good!
Oh my god!
Myuka's back!
Oh, move?
No, no.
This is the awkward thing where you and an on-comer are
about to walk into each other but both dodge the same way.
the easy guy truck
you guys there's no crack there's no crack
Where'd the auto stop?
Auto.
Hide.
It's very sudsy.
I was just going, Papa, Papa.
You know, Maika, how long until you're with me to go to the
bathroom?
In the middle of the time, I don't know if you'll be like
that, or will you say to me?
I'll go to the bathroom instead of saying something like
that, or something like that.
And then, when you know that I'm a good boy,
No, not allowed.
No,
please give me your sister.
No.
Oh,
my God.
So that she never gets a boyfriend.
The foolproof plan.
Good idea, Mioka.
Good idea.
My kitty mind control.
Oops.
Oh.
Because you're tight.
Before you let it in,
It is a little annoying.
Thank you.
Everyone's getting influenced by the skincare set.
Smoother with their hot headlights.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder if you fail this, though.
We'll do an experiment.
If you fail the skincare, what happens?
Yuka, you're already beautiful.
Beautiful!
The skin melts off.
Probably.
Just like the scene in Indiana Jones.
They just melt into a skeleton.
Okay.
Oh wait, this one's not timed!
Just kidding, okay.
It's only yoga, I guess you can fail.
Do you guys think I paid too much for this game?
Actually, I love stupid games like this, though.
Stupid positive.
Oh, no, you got it in your hair!
No.
Skincare.
End.
Very good.
Good, good, good, good.
I'm going to do my skincare like this tonight, everybody.
Why does it smell bad?
It shouldn't.
Shake,
shake, shake, shake, shake, shake.
What is Minto skin routine?
In the mornings, I...
Protruding.
But...
I rinse my face, and then I do vitamin C serum, and I do
another, like, hydrating serum, and then I do...
I do moisturizer.
and then it's like a light moisturizer and then I do
sunscreen and then at night I do I wash my face and then I
do the moisturizing serum again and then I do a bit of a
heavier like hydrating serum and then I do what do I do next
oh I do A bit of a heavier moisturizer.
Yes.
It's pretty basic.
Does it get tedious?
It can.
It can, it can.
Sometimes I'm just like, I don't want to do it.
Is that a twice a day thing?
Morning and night.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's pretty basic, I think.
I do have, like, some, like, skincare devices I use, too,
but that's after I put on everything.
Just don't go out the sun.
Also, avoid moonlight.
I am 85.
I don't look at you for 37.
I believe you.
Let's see.
Since all...
Let's do one more, like, game game.
Oh, wait.
We could do a different outfit this time, though.
Yeah!
Okay.
Can I still do stocking?
It's peak!
You got... Oh my god, it's so good.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, whoops.
We...
We'll go do another, like, one in the street.
Actually, I wonder if I should do...
Rin, though, because it'll be more difficult.
No, it's okay.
I'll just do.
Residence.
Okay.
Wasted.
We're wasted.
Night pool on the streets.
Oh, we get to see a few guys casual.
Why is she rubbing her hands like that?
What is she skimming?
Yeah, where'd the stockings go?
Hi!
Look at her abs though!
Her abs go crazy!
Wait, if I press R, Oh, okay, just kidding.
Oh, Arie says display log.
Sorry, I thought it would be the wind again.
Oh, so that's why...
Wait, there's different dialogue for it?
No way.
Oh, I wonder if it's scripted.
That's why.
Oh.
Maybe that's why we're not wearing the...
Stockings.
But I'm sorry.
You were supposed to be the designated walker.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I'm just a very big one.
I'm getting my favorite.
I'm just woken to the other day.
I'm just a little bit tired.
I'm just going to go to the party.
Is it right now?
Is it a nightclub?
But if you're too late, I might.
But if I'm not too much and I'm going to go, then I should
go to another day.
I think I'll be the next time.
music makes me want to act silly.
No,
don't cry!
She's crying and I'm dancing.
Those are the most crocodile tears ever.
You stop crying immediately.
Let's go home!
Okay.
Alright, lock-in, everybody.
Let's go home!
And not explode.
Not explode.
But I'm gonna get those underwear.
I'm gonna get these panties.
I'm gonna get them.
Oh my god, the stockings are so good!
Get it!
Wait, the stockings are too good!
Okay.
So far so good.
Densets no?
No, I don't think so.
They're not the legendary panties of Akihabara,
unfortunately.
Ouch.
No, you're not gonna force me to go through these.
Oh my god, please.
Please don't do this to me.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god.
Okay, we got this.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, we've been...
I made it!
Okay.
Why?
Oh my god, that was close to you guys.
But this is, this is a pretty, pretty smooth run, I'd say.
We picked wasted, right?
Hold on, I'm gonna get the panties.
Ouch.
No!
Okay?
Turn around?
Flip it around?
Wicked wits!
I wonder, let's try going around these, actually.
What if she swings around on the pole?
That'd be crazy.
Wait, can... Oh, there's a... there's a convenience here.
Yeah!
Destruction!
Yeah, baby!
Whoa, I saw inside her head.
There's not a thought behind those eyes, actually.
Okay, awesome.
Nice.
Get the!
I don't think it's very rare.
I think it's normal, actually.
Alright, this way.
I can't see.
Okay.
I don't think I can go across this, that pretty sketchy
looking one.
It's really thin.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god, okay.
Alright, alright, alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
No!
Painful.
Yeah, imagine when the owner looks together she sees a girl
in a bathing suit wearing stockings.
Like, going like...
Oh, shoot!
Oh my god!
Get soaked by a fire hydrant is an achievement.
That's crazy.
Dude, convenience stores in Japan sell pants too.
I think they sell boxers, actually.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
You got this?
Please.
It's scary.
It's too scary.
Oh, okay, we got this.
Nice guys, good job.
Let's see.
to decide which way i want to go uh let's try to just go and
wait i could go around it maybe let me just not explode
here here here like this okay okay we gotta go across here
though oh my god oh my god oh my god No, no, no, no, don't
explode!
Don't explode!
Okay, that was close.
Ah!
I got greedy.
No!
But we got it.
We got that one.
I don't have to try again, I suppose.
Was it worth it?
Maybe.
Okay.
I wonder what other things you can hit, then that gives you,
like, special...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please!
Oh, it's so it's so it's so...
Oh, that was scary for real.
Okay.
Please.
I need you to focus.
Ren.
Ren, please focus!
You heard those pretty lines.
Okay,
please.
Yeah, super yabai.
Super yabai.
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
Oh, so dang!
She died, for real!
I don't think you're gun-bottowing enough, Rin.
I think you're...
You're not taking this very seriously.
Drowned in way.
concrete actually though.
All
right.
Heat it up, heat it up, heat it up.
And okay.
Oh no no no!
I was trying to turn her.
Oh.
Guys, this is pretty tough.
This is pretty tough.
Come on Rin, I need you to focus.
Girl!
No!
I need you to focus for real!
Pour the concrete.
Oh, it's Rin's unlucky day because in the morning comes the
team that's going to pour in the concrete here and they're a
team they call Never Look Twice because they'll never look
to make sure that it's that it's empty.
They only notoriously look once Because they think that
they'll get the job done right in the first try Oh my god,
please And so, Rin will die
She's already wearing a swimsuit and then takes damage What
does she lose?
That's a great question That's a great question, let's test
it
All right, just a little bit more.
No!
Oh,
our heat is going crazy.
I wish I could just go through these.
But unfortunately...
Oh.
you can't you just take a bunch of damage oh gosh okay i was
just gonna test it but i guess not okay all right you got
this you got this rin you got this run you got this oh my
gosh no no no no
make sure there's nothing behind me too.
No hidden Ponsu behind me?
Bridges and Dems are haunted because if someone fell into a
support while it was being poured, we could not stop the
poor to save them.
It's true.
Oh my god.
Wait, we're going crazy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, no!
I need you to focus!
Ran, I need you to focus!
Come on.
You do,
yeah...
You do seem like you're gonna fall.
It's okay now.
Okay, now.
Okay, I'm not gonna...
Okay, alright, we're gonna...
We just gotta get through this part, you guys.
We just gotta get through this one part!
That's gore of my comfort character.
Come on.
This way?
You're okay.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Sorry.
Oh, okay.
Alright, this way?
We're collecting damage.
That's okay.
Hitbox.
It's because she's wearing heels.
Ma'am, I need you to take those off.
You know, there's, um, if you wear, like, heels.
Oh my god.
Turn around!
Um, there's like, uh, there's like foldable shoes that you
can buy for when your feet get tired of wearing heels.
So you can just like, just pull them out of your bag and be
like, okay.
This is the final boss level for Halo.
I couldn't line it up.
for the concrete.
She wants to eat concrete so stinkin' by it.
I don't know if we should Zen-Lyoku dash.
I think we should take it nice and easy.
Okay, yeah.
Wasted.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I avoided that box.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
I ate my words.
Heals can help you run from T-Rex's.
What is that from?
Okay, I gotta, I'm gonna Rock in.
Please.
I need- No, no, why are you turning around?
Why are you turning around?
No, oh my god.
That almost exploded.
Holy cow.
That would have been so bad.
Okay, come on.
Forward.
Forward, Rin.
Please.
No, no, don't fall, please.
Don't fall.
Please.
Don't watch yourself.
Why did you turn around?
I'm gonna have a cough drop.
And then...
Why did you turn around?
I just want to go home, honestly.
This game is making it hard for me to love them.
I don't think I love you anymore.
Why did you turn around?
Why did you do that?
Jurassic World got made fun of a lot for you.
Oh, really?
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on.
Yeah.
One step forward.
One foot forward.
No, please.
Please.
God, please.
God, please, please.
I will- I'm a good ghost.
I promise.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Okay, we're- We're shimmying.
We're shimmying through it.
We're shimmying through it!
Yeah!
Ouch!
I thought you meant ouchi.
ouchi, ouchi!
ouchi!
I wish there was another way to get through this.
They're like, you're gonna get good at this game.
Or you'll never make it through.
We tank it, we tank these.
We tank these.
Please.
We shimmy through.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, all right.
No, okay, we can avoid that one at least.
I see the goal!
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, no, why are you gonna turn him out?
Okay, we're fine.
Just kidding.
Sorry.
I'm fine?
I'm normal?
Everything's good?
Okay.
Ouch!
This one I think we can go around too.
It's not worth it.
I'll chat, I'll chat, I'll chat.
It's okay.
Goal.
Just get to the goal.
Yes.
Her butt is stuck!
Good job, Mido.
Thank you!
Congrats on walking.
It's my first day on Earth!
She's like, it'd be so bad if someone saw me like this.
But it'd also be so bad if the construction workers came
back and started pouring.
the concrete.
Wait, so this is a different...
This should be a different game then, right?
Or the different minigame.
This game making Dark Souls look like a baby game.
Your butt got stuck in a manhole!
I gotta shake my body and escape.
Obviously.
By pressing the button displayed until the gauge disappears,
you may shake your body.
Upon shaking your body enough and escaping, you will clear
the game.
Oh, please.
You can't get out of that.
I want to know how... Oh, wait.
Oh, I want to know how the, like, meeting for this, you
know, like, how do we do this mini-game?
Look at her face.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, they're getting fast.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No way, full combo!
Oh, I wonder because I didn't fail this time, I got an S.
Whoa!
Everyday clothes.
Let's see what panties we get.
Oh, wow, passionate rose.
Pure strawberry!
Her butt is nowhere big enough to be stuck in them.
I know!
She just wants to be held, okay guys?
Rabbit whiskers are so cute!
Gothic devil purple.
Very cute!
No Rin, don't jump!
It's concrete!
What's dripping?
I guess from the pool?
The concrete.
The concrete's dripping.
Oh, okay.
She's in a kitty pool.
So then it'll be safe.
Yeah, guys, don't drink and swim, okay?
It's dangerous.
Don't drink and swim!
You should go into a kitty pool.
Yeah, wait, only 50%?
What if you're swimming in alcohol though?
You can swim in piles of money like your Scrooge McDuck.
That's the only time.
Morrow, thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you think?
Wait, do we get a CG?
She's gonna drag her in.
Hot tub stream on balcony.
What?
Step construction work, I'm sorry.
That's okay.
Imagine you come across two girls in a kitty pool in the
middle of an alleyway.
I don't think that's what I don't I mean that's a nice thing
to say but I don't think that applies here like I'm
beautiful so you don't need a bathing suit what's that mean
unless she's asking her to be naked
goodbye organs
Maybe I'll do it one day so that you guys can be like, oh my
god, you'll never guess what happened to me.
I was walking down an alleyway and I saw a girl swimming in
a kitty pool.
Oh,
what?
No CG.
Really?
Stingy game, stingy game, stingy game.
alleyway is haunted there's a ghost swimming here well guys
um this game was fun wasn't it there's still so many outfits
unlock maybe why is she crying this one's cute though this
is a cute pose me too
I wonder how tall she is.
Probably, we're about...
Probably, like, maybe...
I don't know.
I don't know how tall she is.
Do you think we're about the same height?
Maybe...
She seems tall, though, right?
Hey!
Wait, I want her in her actual outfit.
Wait, then change the pose.
Oh wait, I feel like taller.
Well, she's wearing heels right now, so.
Wait, did she actually get taller?
Wow!
I think she actually got taller because of the heels.
Wait, unless she was in heels before.
Let's see what other pose that we got.
You're walking in the street.
There's no one around and your phone is dead.
Out of the corner of your eye.
Ah!
Is it because I'm a ghost?
This is cute pose too.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, sorry.
There we go.
I want to look at me now.
Wait, I can do something else too.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I might be a genius.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I might be a genius!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
I forgot to do this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, uh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Uh, over here.
Now I'm really in there with...
The lighting is simpler even.
This is sooo!
Women, am I right?
Positive.
Thank you guys for joining me for Mary Bunny Girl.
This was so silly.
I thought the the games would be a little bit longer but um
this was still fine so thank you everybody thank you i hope
you have a good day i hope you have a good night i hope you
have a good time so let me and me and nin-chan are gonna um
we're also gonna have a fun we're gonna we're gonna hang out
and watch the anime together totally wholesome game have a
good resume though youtube here look thank you
Nawa!
Thank you so much for the tag!
After that, girl!
Thank you, thank you!
Okie dokie, everybody.
Okie dokie?
Art of chokies?
Yeah, we're gonna go do skincare together!
So true!
Oh my gosh!
I actually get to go try my new skincare!
I'm excited, I'm excited.
I like when I move, my feet kind of shuffle.
Okay!
Utsumi-ta!
Bye-bye, bye-bye